ja heute wollen wir mit aktuellen
bildern beginn aus der ukraine und zwar
aus der ostukrainischen stadt charkiw
jemals 1,4 millionen einwohner wir
erinnern uns an den ersten kriegswochen
war die stadt schon eingekesselt die
russen standen direkt davor von drei
seiten jetzt ist die stadt ein bisschen
wieder befreit worden man hat die russen
zurückgeschlagen aber sie hören nicht
auf dort zu bomben- und das sind bilder
aus der letzten nacht dort wurden
wohnviertel in der stadt erneut von
russland angegriffen und bombardiert und
wir wissen aktuell dass es sechs tote
und 16 verletzte dort gegeben hat alles
zivilisten das wie gesagt die die bilder
aus der letzte start und wir sehen dass
gleich noch mal aus einer anderen
perspektive wie dort einfach ganz
normale wohnhäuser ich ganz normale
altbauten hier können sie das mal
angucken bloß und die fassade steht wir
sehen also durch jedes fenster hier
sehen wir das feuer dahinter das heißt
wir haben es nur noch die fassade aber
dahinter ist leider dann alles zerstört
worden wie gesagt es gab wieder tote und
verletzte putins brutaler krieg richtet
sich auch weiter gegen die
zivilbevölkerung der ukraine und
keinesfalls wie putin ja behauptet und
russland behauptet ausschließlich gegen
das ukrainische militär wir wollen uns
weitere bilder ansehen aus dem osten des
landes war wollen wir uns mal ansehen
die realität und die propaganda der
sogenannten volksrepublik lukas die
volksrepublik nur ganz ist seit 2014
schon damals vom russischen geheimdienst
etabliert worden hat mittlerweile wir
sehen es hier im osten des landes die
gesamte region lukas auch erobert
zusammen mit russischer hilfe und diese
marionetten behaupten ja dass sie eine
eigene miliz hätten sozusagen und dass
sie eigentlich sind und wir sind jetzt
hier mal wie ein propagandavideo der
volksrepublik aussieht das sind also die
soldaten hier vom panzer grüßen die
arbeiter vorrücken wie und das muss man
tatsächlich sagen putin verlässt sich
sehr auf wie die auch ein großteil der
last getragen dass das forscht vorstoßes
tragen gegen die ukrainische truppen
aber die frage ist woher kommen denn
diese menschen sind das tatsächlich
ukrainer die sagen wir hassen die
ukraine das sind alles nazis wir wollen
hier für russland kämpfen das sind es
zum großen teil nicht sondern wir haben
es hier mit zwangs mobilisierten jungen
männern zu tun die überhaupt nicht
kämpfen wollen die eigentlich bloß ein
friedliches leben haben wollen aber
jetzt zur front gebeten müssen wir also
gezwungen werden und wir sehen uns mal
an wie das funktioniert ist kein ganz
neues video aus einem kindergarten in
der region lugano ein kindergarten wo
ein vater seine beiden kinder abholen
wollte aber
hat es nicht so weit geschafft und
dieses video ist jetzt von einer
erzieherin des kindergartens und wir
sehen einfach mal wie der vater vor dem
kindergarten von zwei soldaten gefangen
genommen wird ja entführt wird kann man
sagen und dann eben zwangs mobilisiert
wird hier also eben ganz kurz zu sehen
wie der mann da sich noch verteidigt wer
sich wehrt jahre von zwei anderen
männern festgehalten wird oder drei
männern die alle versuchen ihnen dort
mitzunehmen das wie gesagt ein vater der
eigentlich seine kinder abholen wird
aber jetzt zu kanonenfutter für putins
krieg und das sind die ukraine aus nur
hans aus der ukrainischen regionen du
kannst die gezwungen werden gegen andere
ukraine zu bekämpfen und gegen diese ja
und zu töten oder selbst vorbei zu
sterben wir wissen dass hunderte von
denen tagtäglich sterben und am ende
sehen wir noch ein ganz interessantes
bild was schon einige tage all das auch
dass ein video hier ja man kann es kaum
glauben das sind die jungen männer die
einfach eingesammelt werden von der
straße weggeschnappt werden weggefangen
werden von den soldaten hier sehen wir
sie und dann auf die militärlaster
abgefahren werden nach ein zwei wochen
müssen die an die front müssen dort
artillerie bedienen müssen panzer
bedienen machen das komplett ohne jede
vorbildung und deshalb eben auch mit
diesen riesigen verlusten die sie gegen
die ukrainische armee erleiden also man
sieht es hier tatsächlich mitten im
sommer die haben kurze hosen an die
hatten überhaupt nicht damit gerechnet
dass sie irgendwie zum kriegseinsatz
gerufen werden aber sie werden auf diese
moral lkw gepackt die anderen passen auf
dass sie nicht abhauen und kurz danach
müssen sie schon an der front auf ihre
landsleute schießen und dort ukraine
töten oder von ukrainern getötet werden
[Musik]